Um,
so I'm going to continue talking
about a renal physiology today. Again,
this is covered in chapter nine.
You'll,
you will have noticed as you're reading
chapter nine that there's more covered
than just a renal physiology there.
It also talks about bio transformations
and the role of the liver in getting rid
of substances. So we're not going to
cover that part in class, but, uh, but I,
but I encourage you to read
it as a whole, uh, to get, uh,
a broader perspective of how kidney
function fits into the overall ability of
your body to maintain what we call
homeostasis or a constant environment,
which I talked about last time.
One of the important elements of this
constant environment is to maintain
sodium, potassium, bicarbonate,
and the levels of other key molecules at
a constant level throughout the day and
throughout your life. And, uh,
it does that and you're able to do that
not by regulating how much you eat of
those things,
but the kidney does that
for you by sensing what
concentrations are in your body,
keeping what you need and getting
rid of what you don't need.
And we started talking about how the
kidney is able to accomplish this
remarkable, uh, task. And, um,
hopefully the main point I wanted to make
a in the last lecture was how grateful
you ought to be that your
kidneys do function properly.
Because as one of the results of
that is that you only have to, uh,
you only have to produce about a liter
or a liter and a half of urine per day to
get rid of all the,
all the waste products that are
produced by metabolism in your body.
Without that concentrating
ability of your kidney, I mean,
the ability of the kidney to produce a
urine that's very concentrated in waste
rather than dilute in waste,
uh,
you only have to relieve yourselves and
a liter and a half of fluid every day
instead of the hundred or so leaders
that you'd have to in the absence of that
ability to concentrate.
And that makes possible a lot of
the things that we enjoy in life,
like sitting through a 50
minute lecture. Right? So, uh,
what I want to talk about today is some
of how the, how the kidney does that.
And I'm going to go back a few
steps because I covered a lot.
I wanted to give you an overview at
the end of sort of the last half of the
lecture last time about
how the nephron functions.
And I'm going to go back now and step
through it a little bit more slowly and
talk about some of the
details. Now, the, the, the,
like the other systems we've talked about,
the brain,
the heart, the circulatory system, uh,
the kidney has a very sort of
rich and complex physiology,
which now we understand a fairly well.
And so we're only going to
scratch the surface of that.
And if you get excited about it, um,
there are ways for to learn more,
uh, in your time here at Yale
and certainly beyond. Okay.
So, uh, this is a picture that I showed
you before sorta to orient you again.
And I have this picture of a
kidney, uh, lying on its side,
right? And, uh, it's a layered structure.
The outer layer or the sort of shell
around the outside of the kidney.
This fibrous capsule,
which sort of distinguishes what's
inside the kidney from what's outside the
kidney.
The layer below that is called the cortex.
The inner layers that have these sort of
strike patients is called the Medulla.
And all of this comes together in this
region here called the renal pelvis.
This region where the renal artery enters
the renal vein leaves and the ureter
exits the kidney as well.
Okay?
So everything collects sort of at
what's at the bottom of this diagram,
but it would be on the, um, the uh,
insight or a medial surface of the kidney.
And it's in its anatomic position.
I mentioned last time that the
functional units of the kidney are this,
uh, this, uh, structure called a Nephron,
that each kidney has about a million of
these nephrons and that they're oriented
within these layers.
So a nephron is going to sit sort of on
this axis here going up and down in this
diagram. So that's the reason why
I turned this kidney on its side.
So when you look at the Nephron here,
you can think about it sitting in
this orientation, uh, in the kidney.
And of course the kidney has
this sort of curved structures.
So the nephrons are going
to sort of radiate out from
the central portion in, uh,
through the Medela and up into the cortex
with the Glomerulus near the cortex
and the loop of Henley
stretching down into the Medela.
I also, uh, mentioned several
features of the nephron.
One is the glomerulus
where the, uh, the, the,
the place where filtration takes place,
this tuft of capillaries
that surrounded by a capsule.
And so the capsule is there to catch
this filtrate that's produced by high
pressure inside the arterial system,
forcing some fluid out through
these leaky capillaries and the,
and the capsule called Bowman's capsule
is there to catch this fluid and started
on its way through this series of tubules.
And I talked about different
regions of the tubules,
the proximal convoluted tubule, proximal
because it's near the gum aerialists,
the loop of Henley,
this structure that stretches down through
the cortex into the Mandala and then
back up again. And the
distal convoluted Tubule, uh,
which is farther from the glomerulus
and empties into the collecting duct,
which then
moves down through the Cortex,
through the Medela and into this region
of the renal pelvis where all the
collecting ducts empty into the
ureter and then onto the bladder.
So,
uh,
so a filtrate of plasma is produced here
in the Glomerulus and as this filtrate
of plasma,
this fluid that is going to be urine at
some point moves through this series of
tubules. It gets, uh, it gets
processed, it gets modified,
it gets changed and in particular,
the cells of these tubules are able to
reabsorb the molecules that you need.
They reabsorb a lot of water,
they reabsorb a lot of sodium,
potassium bicarbonate,
and they do that without reabsorbing.
A lot of the waste products you
don't need like urea. Okay. And, uh,
as you might guess,
given this configuration that there's
some interplay between the activities that
happen at different parts of
the tubule. That is, if, if,
uh, sodium is being reabsorbed in
the proximal Tubule, which it is,
then that, where does
that sodium go? Right.
It's pumped out of the 2
billion into this space around.
Okay.
In the, into the space of the
kidney surrounding it. Nate,
would you mind getting the door
again? Sorry about that. Uh,
in sodium is going to accumulate out here.
Now where does that sodium go?
Well eventually it's going to go back
into the blood so there must be a lot of
blood vessels around there as well.
They're not shown in this diagram.
There'll be shown in the next one.
So this sodium leaves the leaves,
the leaves the urine through the walls
of the tubules and is reabsorbed back
into blood vessels. But that leaves
some sodium out here in this space.
And one of the really interesting
things about the kidney,
which we won't be about the Nephron in
particular that we won't be able to talk
about it in so much detail is how one
part of the tubule system uses the result
of the other in order to
establish gradients to produce
this concentrated urine.
We're not really going to talk about that,
but I wanted to mention it on
this diagram here, that there's a,
that there's a,
that there are real important reasons
why the tubules are arranged in the
anatomical pattern,
that they are.
An additional thing,
which I mentioned last time,
is that if you looked as
cell biologists did at the,
at the cells that make up
these linings of these tubules,
you'd find that they look different
in different parts of the nephron.
And this has to do with
their different functions.
Some are very good at reabsorbing sodium,
some are very good at reabsorbing water
and uh, some are good at other functions.
And so the function of each of these
groups of cells that make up different
portions of the Tubule, uh, is critical
for overall nephron function. And we'll,
we'll,
I'll say a little bit about that just to
give you a flavor for how that happens
without talking too
much about the details.
Okay.
So this shows, uh, a collection
of nephrons sort of in,
in a more complex arrangement.
I've got the kidney here,
so you can be reminded again that this
might be a structure that comes from here.
Uh, and then you can see several
nephrons in particular. There's, uh,
there's a lot of glow marea lie in
this picture where the nephron that's
associated with this goal. Marea listen,
this girl, Mary, let's aren't shown, uh,
so that we can focus on, on,
uh, just uh, just a few of them.
Uh,
but just to give you a sense for this
million nephrons that are arranged in the
kidney or they have their go
your light, I different, uh,
at different locations up and down,
they are surrounded by their proximal
and distal convoluted tubules and these
loops of Henley stretched down into the
[inaudible] region and then come back up.
And I wanted to use this more complicated
diagram to sort of illustrate the
flow. How does fluid move
through this, through this, uh,
through one particular nephron within
this system here. And so I hope this,
uh, this comes out. Can you see the
red? Did you see the Red Arrow up here?
So that Red Arrow represents
arterial flow of blood.
And this is a branch of the renal artery,
which is serving this whole
collection of nephrons that are here.
And of course that vessel
branches at some point.
And here I show a branch of a branch,
which is heading up towards these Gomera
lie up in this upper region of the
Cortex,
right?
So blood is flowing through these
branches of the renal artery into the,
into the,
um,
the substance of the kidney and it flows
up into Oakland. Marion, let's here now,
because this is,
um,
this is not too distant
to branch from the aorta,
pressure is still high here.
You know that pressure remains pretty
high until you get down to the arterial
levels, right? We learned that
when we talked about the cert,
the circulatory system.
And so the pressure here is fairly high,
might be 70 or 80 millimeters of mercury.
And this is the pressure that
drives filtration in the Mary Lists.
So the Green Arrow,
which just appeared up here,
is supposed to indicate for
this goal, Mary Alice, right
there. Filtration happens.
Yeah.
And because of the pressure
drop in the [inaudible],
the low pressure in Bowman's space,
this space that surrounds it,
fluid is driven through the walls of
the capillary and collected outside.
And what is produced there is
really what I called last time,
an ultra filtrate of plasma that is the
urine or the filtrate that's going to
become end at this point
would be identical to plasma
in composition except all
the big items are removed.
All the large molecules,
all the cells are removed.
Other than that, it's identical.
So the concentration of sodium in
the field trade is the same as the
concentration of sodium and the
plasma concentration of urea,
same as concentration in the plasma
concentration of bicarbonate and so on.
As long as any molecule
that's below that cutoff,
it's going to have the same concentration
as it is in plasma. So there,
this green Arrow represents filtration.
From there,
the fluid moves through the
distal convoluted tubules,
which you can't really see here, but
it's up in this portion. The white,
if you can see on the uh,
here that some of these are
white and some of them are blue.
The white ones are the
proximal convoluted tubule,
but they're really not liking the diagram
before these, these convoluted tubules,
they're sort of mixed together,
right? They interact with one another,
uh,
that this filtrate goes
through the proximal convoluted
tubule down in the loop
of Henley. And now you can see, follow
these green arrows. It's moving down.
It takes a turn,
deepen them Adela,
and starts coming back up again and um,
and heads back up to the
distal convoluted tubule.
Now we're not going to talk
about it at all in this class,
but if you go on to study, uh, physiology,
one of the most amazing things
about the Nephron is it's, uh,
is that this loop allows the nephron to
create a gradient of osmolarity within
the tissue,
outside the nephrons in the kidney.
And it's able to create a
concentration gradient of sodium,
basically a but of ions that it
can then use to reabsorb water.
So Austin was sitting
in the front last time,
mentioned that she thought Osmosis was an
important part of how the kidney works.
And it is osmotic forces
are how water concentration,
how water moves around in the kidney,
and the kidney is able to regulate how
concentrated or how dilute your urine is
by using osmotic gradients.
And those osmotic gradients
are established in the
loop of Henley. And it's a,
it's, it's, it's really
a remarkable, um, uh,
a remarkable sort of biophysical,
a process that you'll learn about
if you study more renal physiology.
But there's a reason why the fluid goes
down and goes up and it's to establish
these gradients which the kidney uses
to concentrate or extract water from the
urine.
Uh,
this orange Arrow here represents the
flow going from the distal convoluted
tubule back into the collecting duct
and down through the collecting duct and
eventually into the
ureter. And so this, um,
is just a more complicated diagram
of what I've told you already.
Uh, and I encourage you to sort of walk
through it and look at all the parts that
you have a sense for how the anatomy
of the, uh, of the, uh, uh, kidney,
uh, works. This picture
I showed you before,
just to remind you of the first step
in producing urine is filtration.
And I've talked about
it several times now,
but there's this tuft of capillaries
which sits inside this capsule called
Bowman's capsule. Uh, there's
an artery which feeds, uh,
which feeds blood in,
called the afferent arterial
af af parent means towards,
so it's the,
uh,
it's the arterial that's carrying
blood towards the glomerulus.
And oops,
I went the wrong way somehow.
And the F Behrendt arterial,
which carries a, which carries
the blood out of the [inaudible],
right?
So now the flow rates here
would be different, right?
The blood that's flowing
through the [inaudible], the,
the amount of blood flowing through the
afferent arterial and the mouth flowing
through the f Faron deteriorate.
Arterial f ferret meaning away from our
different, because some fluids lost.
That's the amount that's
filtered into Bowman's space. Um,
and we talked about last time that these
are both arterials and that because
their arterials, they
can constrict or, or, or,
or reduce their diameters and expand,
dilate,
or expand their diameters.
And because of this,
if it constricts than
the pressure drop over,
that length of arterial
is going to change.
Right,
and having these two adjustable
resistances on both sides of the Golem
aerialists allows each nephron to
regulate what the pressure is in the fluid
inside the capillaries of the Glomerulus.
Now,
since it's pressure
inside these capillaries,
which is the driving force for filtration,
that means that each nephron has the
ability to adjust how much is filtered in
each column aerialists.
Now that if it were going to in a slide
or two going to talk about a concept
called the gold [inaudible] filtration
rate and that this is a concept that's
defined for your whole kidneys and the
goal American look, filtration rate,
we all have a glomerular filtration rate.
It's the rate at which filtrate is being
produced in all the Gulmarg ally of our
kidneys.
It's the rate at which the fluid that's
going to become urine is produced.
It's an important measure of how well
your kidney is functioning is how much
filtrate is producing per minute.
And what I want to emphasize
on this diagram here,
that another remarkable thing about the
function of the kidney is that each of
these individual million or 2 million
nephrons are able to adjust their
individual filtration rate by
changing the pressure within, uh,
within the goal.
Maryville is,
and of course this was a picture I showed
you last time of the actual filtration
membrane,
the surface of these capillaries where
this pressure drop acts and through which
large things are filtered out.
So here's, uh, uh,
a cartoon of the gold lists.
And this cartoon actually
shows, uh, several things. One,
it shows the, the, uh, the arteriole,
the afferent arterial that's coming in
and the efferent arterial is going out.
And so here's the Tuft of capillaries
that make up the [inaudible] and here's
Bowman's space which is ready to catch
the filtrate. And so this Arrow here,
this first Arrow represents the,
um,
the filtrate that's produced in
the Glomerulus of this particular,
uh, nephron. Now after that
filtrates produced it, it, it,
it starts to flow through the proximal
convoluted tubule and then through the
loop of Henley and the
distal convoluted tubule.
And eventually be the collecting
duct and as we know from last time,
several things can happen.
One is that molecules within this
fluid can be reabsorbed and if they're
reabsorbed they move out of the tubular
system and into back into blood.
And that's why there are blood vessels
surrounding all the nephrons in the
kidney so that there's so there's a
blood flow that's ready to catch these
molecules as their
reabsorbed from the tubules.
We also mentioned that there is some
special processes of secretion so that the
blood vessels in the kidney are smart
enough to detect some molecules and
secrete them actively into the,
into the urine,
and then whatever is not reabsorbed.
Plus what's secreted is what ends up in
the urine after it flows through all the
tubules.
So what's different here is that instead
of showing the complex geometry of the
tubules, this just shows a tube which
is going to the bladder down here.
And this,
this diagram is simplified because I
wanted to just talk about one concept and
that's this glove Merial
or filtration rate.
The rate at which fluid is produced in
the [inaudible] of all of the kidneys.
Now, and the question is how would you
measure this glomerular filtration rate in
people? If it's an important measure of
kidney function, how would you measure it?
And it turns out that that physiologists
have learned how to measure it by
taking advantage of a particular
molecule called Inulin.
Inulin is a molecule that's not a normal
part of our diet. It's a polysaccharide,
but it's a polysaccharide that is of of
sort of intermediate molecular weight.
I think it's about a thousand
or 2000 and molecular weight,
but your body doesn't
know how to digest it.
And so if you get inulin in your blood,
it just circulates and
isn't changed at all.
But it's small that it's
filtered in the glomerulus.
And so if there's Inulin in the blood,
then it gets filtered through the Glenn
Marya lists and ends up in the ultra
filtrate.
Another remarkable property about
Inulin is that it's not reabsorbed.
There's no reason for your body to
reabsorb it because it's not something you
can really use. You don't need it
and it's not actively secreted.
So whatever gets filtered
ends up in the urine.
So this molecule turns out to be a
convenient tool that physicians can use to
measure your glove law filtration rate
in the event that they want to test your
kidney function. So how would you do that?
You would inject an an amount of, uh,
of Inulin into the blood and
you would measure how much,
um, how much, what's the
concentration of inulin in the plasma?
So you'd,
you would inject some amount of Inulin
and you'd measure how much of it is in
the plasma.
You then wait over some period of time
and you would collect the urine and you'd
measure how much of that inulin
appears in the urine. Now,
since Inulin is neither
reabsorbed nor secreted,
however many molecules of Inulin are
filtered at the Mary has to be the same as
the number of molecules
that enter the urine, right?
It's not reabsorbed,
it's not secreted.
So whatever number of molecules
enter here, they have to leave here.
So if I know the concentration
of Inulin in the urine,
I know how much urine is produced
over some period of time.
I know the concentration in the plasma.
Remember that one of the features of
this ultra filtrate is that it just cuts
off in molecular weight,
but whatever concentration,
if you're below that molecular way,
whatever concentration is in the plasma
is the same as the initial concentration
in the ultra filtrate.
And,
and so the plasma in
concentration is the same here.
So if I just do a simple
accounting for all the Inulin,
whatever the glomerular
filtration rate is,
times the concentration in the plasma has
to equal whatever the concentration in
the urine is times the, uh,
the rate of urine production.
I can measure in a person how much
you're in, they're producing per time.
You can measure the concentration
of insulin in the urine.
You can measure the
concentration in the blood,
and so you can calculate the
[inaudible] filtration rate. All right,
so this is a,
a method that takes advantage
of the unique properties
of this molecule in Ulan.
This is a, their physicians
use this general strategy.
In a variety of ways to measure flow
rates of things inside your body that are
difficult to measure directly.
And they do that by looking at what's
called a tracer molecule. In this case,
insulin is a tracer.
It's picked for its particular properties
that it's filtered freely and the Gold
Mary lists, but neither
reabsorbed, dark or are secreted.
And it allows you to calculate some uh,
um,
some physiological function sort of deep
inside your body so you can measure go
mango,
look filtration rate this way.
I've already showed you this
picture that shows uh, the,
the um, the, uh,
the vascular system of the kidney
sort of laid out in a line here.
So here's the renal artery branching into
f fair af Barrett arterials branching
into glomerular capillaries back into
[inaudible], arterioles and then, uh,
to the capillaries that surround the
tubules and the pressure dropped that are
associated with that.
And I show it just to remind you of
how the kidney could regulate its Mary
filtration rate by changing the diameters
of either the [inaudible] or the
afferent arterial,
changing the resistances,
changing the relative pressure
drops along the kidney vasculature.
And therefore regulating the
important level, which is here.
How much pressure is in the glove
aerialist to drive filtration, right? So,
um, I've talked about this
several times now and I,
I think if you study that
diagram and read the text,
hopefully that will make sense to you.
But it is this pressure is what
drives inside the Glove Marea list,
the flow of, uh, of, uh,
filtrate and the production of
filtrate that becomes urine.
So what happens after this point?
What happens are these two processes
that we've talked about that make the
kidney different from a simple filter.
Filtration is an important
part of its function.
That's easy to understand from solar
sort of an engineering perspective.
You produced this ultra filtrate and then
the kidney works very hard to recover
the molecules that you need so that you
don't have to produce a large volume of
urine in order to get rid of the waste.
And it does that by two processes,
reabsorption and secretion,
which I've already mentioned.
And we're really going to focus
mainly on reabsorption, uh,
for the rest of the time here today.
And in reabsorbtion the key,
um,
the key elements of reabsorption are
reabsorption of water or return of much of
this volume of water that's filtered at
the glow Marios and recovery of saw utes
that are needed like sodium and
potassium and bicarbonate. Yeah.
This table just sort of tells you in
general what happens at different portions
of the,
of the uh,
nephron filtration happens
in Bowman's capsule.
I think I've said enough about that one.
Selective reabsorption happens in
all other elements of the Tubules,
the proximal,
the loop of Henley and the distal tubule.
And how does selective
reabsorption happens?
It happens by the physical processes
of diffusion or just the movement of
molecules down concentration gradients.
And it also happens by active transport.
And we talked about active transport
earlier we talked for example,
when we were talking about
the action potential,
we talked about this active transport
system that's able to shuttle sodium and
potassium molecules across membranes.
So most cells in the body have this
active transport system called the sodium
potassium pump or the
sodium potassium ATPase.
It's main function is to bring
a sodium from inside the cell,
pump it out,
take potassium from outside the cell
and pump it in and as a result of the
action of this pump,
that's what creates this normal state
that you have high extracellular sodium
concentrations and high intracellular
potassium concentrations,
right?
If that pump wasn't working,
then sodium would diffuse from outside
to in because the concentration is higher
outside than inside and potassium would
diffuse from inside to out because the
concentration's higher
inside than outside.
Now this pump is driven by ATP.
ATP is a molecule.
It's one of the end product.
It's a molecule that's produced when we
metabolize sugars and get energy from
them and we store them in the form of
ATP and then the body uses ATP to do
things like operate this pump.
A lot of the ATP that you're using
right now in your body is being used to
maintain the concentration of sodium high
outside yourselves and potassium high
inside yourselves. Why? Why are, why are
you spending so much energy doing that?
Why do you,
why would you?
Body has spent so much energy trying
to maintain these differences of ion
concentrations.
Remember Justin,
because these concentrations have
to exist for cellular functions like
yeah,
like the generation of action
potentials in the nervous system,
potentials in the heart that that drive
contraction and beating of
the heart. Without these
differences of concentration,
you could neither send nerve impulses.
Your heart would not beat,
maintains life and lots of
the activities of life and,
and so a lot of energy goes
into producing them in, in,
in those same kinds of processes are used
in the kidney to shuttle ions from one
place to another. Show you an example of
that in a minute. Reabsorption of water.
I tried to emphasize last time how
important reabsorption of water is because
you have to produce a lot of filtrate
in order to collect a lot of waste
products,
right?
You've got to produce a lot of filtrate
in order to get a lot of urea into the
urine. You don't want to lose that
much water because any water you lose,
you have to drink to
recover from. And, uh,
so reabsorption of water is,
it is a very important process
that happens in the kidney.
It happens in all the
tubular, uh, segments.
Secretion happens mainly in the distal
convoluted tubule. And as I mentioned,
we're not going to say
very much about that.
So if we were just able to look and take
one nephron and take that complicated
series of tubes that I showed you in
diagrams before and stretch it out while
it's still is functioning and then measure
as a function of distance along this
complicated to bill,
what's the concentration or relative
concentration of some of these key, uh,
molecules we're talking about?
What we would see is shown in this
diagram here and I mentioned the special
property of Inulin,
that it's neither reabsorbed or secreted
and that's shown here by this flat
line.
So whatever gets filtered
in the [inaudible] list,
that number of molecules remains in the
urine throughout its progress through
the Tubules,
right?
That's why you can use it as a tracer
to measure GFR because it's neither
reabsorbed in any of these
tubules north secreted.
So the number of molecules that
come out in the field trait,
that's the number that leave in the urine.
That's not true for glucose.
I mentioned yesterday that glucose is
not normally found in urine when it,
when you do find glucose in the urine
of an individual that indicates that
there's some disease process going on,
and that's because glucose is very
efficiently reabsorbed in the proximal
tubule. So if I just looked at
concentration within the filtrate,
within the urine,
through the proximal Tubule,
there'd be a lot of glucose here and that
concentration drops as we move through
the proximal tubule such that
there's no glucose in the filtrate.
By the time we get to the
end of the proximal Tubule,
that's one of the simpler cases that
glucose is just reabsorbed in the proximal
tubule. Sodium on the other hand
has a much more complicated, uh,
pattern that sodium concentration drops
as you move through the proximal tubule.
So a lot of that sodium is reabsorbed,
about two thirds of it is
reabsorbed in the proximal tubule.
Then if I looked over the loop
of Henley in the descending loop,
the loop that goes down,
actually sodium molecules come back in
and then sodium molecules go
back out in the ascending loop.
And this has to do with the establishment
of gradients of sodium that I
mentioned before in the
interstitial space, uh,
which allows the kidney to,
this represents those,
the sodium that's used to
create those gradients.
Those gradients are used
for water absorption.
And then most of the rest
of the kidney has, uh,
the rest of the sodium is cleaned up or
recovered in the distal tubule and the
collecting tubules, urea, she has
this pattern here a lot reabsorbed,
but then it comes back out again
and then it's reabsorbed finally.
Now some of these things are going to be
hard for you to understand why they go
in and out.
And it has to do with this complex
interplay that I mentioned before between
processes that are happening in
different parts of the Tubule,
establishing gradients that are then
used in different portions to, uh,
to aid in reabsorption.
Okay,
how do these things happen?
How is sodium, for example,
reabsorbed so efficiently
in the proximal tubule?
Well,
I'm going to give you a simple example
of that just so that you have a way of
thinking about the mechanism,
but you're going to remember that
there's more going on than just what I
described. But I imagine that
this is the proximal tubule cell,
a part of the tubule just after Bowman's
space where sodium concentration is
high inside the, uh, filtrate. Right?
What's the concentration of sodium in the
filtrate? Right after the [inaudible]?
It's the same as the
concentration in plasma,
right?
The same as the concentration in plasma.
What's the concentration of sodium
inside cells that line the tubule.
Okay.
Well, like all cells, these
have sodium potassium, uh,
okay.
Pumps. And so the concentration of
sodium inside these cells is low.
Okay.
The intracellular concentration of
sodium is low, high concentration here,
low concentration here. So if this
membrane is permeable to sodium,
it's going to diffuse
from inside to outside.
Okay.
What would it allow the sodium
diffuse through membranes?
Yeah.
Charged molecules don't diffuse
through membranes on their own,
not if it's just a lipid biolayer.
What allows sodium to diffuse?
What kinds of structures allow sodium
to diffuse through a lipid membrane.
Protein channels, ion
channels, sodium channels,
so there must be sodium channels
in these membranes and there are,
and it's the sodium moods through.
Now you have high sodium inside are
higher than before because sodium can leak
through these channels,
but you have on this other surface of
the cell you have a lot of these sodium
potassium pumps and the sodium potassium
pumps are constantly pumping sodium out
and bringing potassium in. Sodium out
potassium man and there's pumps here,
there's pumps here,
there's pumps here, right?
And so any molecules of sodium that enter
this side get efficiently pumped out
through the other side.
Okay.
The net effect of these two processes,
diffusion on this boundary and active
transport on this boundary is that sodium
molecules move from inside
the tube to outside the tube.
Now if sodium concentration is high
here, where's it going to go? Well,
there are blood vessels up here and
they're going to reabsorb this sodium just
by simple diffusion processes as well.
So blood that's flowing through this
region is going to take all the extra
sodium away.
So the net effect here is that sodium
gets moved from in this filtrate,
this urine back into the blood.
Now the,
the property of these cells which
allows this to happen is that the sodium
potassium pumps are only on this surface.
They're not on this surface.
Okay.
The sodium potassium pumps are only on
this surface and not on this surface.
On this surface,
just diffusion of sodium down its gradient
is the only thing that happens in on
this surface that sodium has moved
out into the interstitial space.
So this is one example of the kind of
properties that sells of the tubules use
in order to selectively move a particular
molecule from one side to the other.
What are the properties
that we talked about?
Membranes are leaky and brings our
leaky because they have channels.
Here's a leaky membrane here and membranes
have active transport systems that
move selectively ions from
one side to the other.
All right.
And that's um, this is an example
that shows how that works with sodium.
There are systems that work with all
of the ions that we've talked about,
not in exactly the same way but
with the same sorts of concepts.
Yeah.
I don't want to say too much about
this diagram. I just show that,
show it here so that, uh, you can,
you can look at it, uh, at, at your,
uh,
at your leisure.
That's what you would do
with your leisure time.
If you could study this diagram, which
just shows you something about, uh,
what kinds of transporters are,
are a functioning in different,
different cells of the proximal Tubule,
the uh,
ascending or descending limb
of, of a, of henleys loop,
the distal convoluted tubule,
the collecting duct.
And these are channels that allow for
selective movement of certain kinds of
molecules like sodium,
like glucose, uh, like, uh,
like a bicarbonate.
And,
and this table is a little
bit more complicated than
the one I showed you before,
but just to try to put it all
into perspective again, uh,
that the kidney because of
glomerular filtration produces,
produces, um, per 24 hours.
Um,
I didn't write out 26,000 milliequivalents
of sodium are filtered and almost all
of those are reabsorbed. Only a
few of them are ex greeted. Now,
if you happen to eat a lot more
salt on one day, what would happen?
You would filter more,
you would reabsorb a little less
and you would excrete that balance,
right?
You would filter more because you would
have eaten more salt than you needed. So,
so, so more sodium would appear
in your blood than normal.
The concentration will be slightly higher
in the plasma. You'd filter more of it,
you'd reabsorb less of it, and the
result would be, you would excrete more,
uh, the same thing with potassium
and with these other molecules here.
And interestingly,
what this shows is the percentage of
these molecules that are reabsorbed.
And then in this table here shows you
what part of the tubular system that
reabsorption takes place. So you could
think about that. Uh, if you wanted,
I want to just say one last word about
water balance. And this is just to, uh,
to uh, to illustrate, uh,
the concept of homeostasis that we've
been talking about for all these ions
before that you could think
of your body as a vessel, uh,
where their inputs and output for water.
The input is mainly the water that you
drink or that you take it in food because
some foods contain high quantities
of water to, for a normal individual,
you're going to take about 2.1 liters
of water in per day in food and drink.
You synthesize some water because some
of the chemical reactions that occur
during metabolism have
water as a byproduct, right?
Have waters of byproducts.
So you synthesize some water.
So your overall daily intake is
about 2.3 liters of water per day.
And you have to get rid of that water
because if you're taking in water and
you're not getting rid of it, then
you're expanding your volume, right?
And,
uh,
so you get rid of it in a variety of
ways about a liter and a half in urine,
almost a third of a leader through your
lungs because you breathe in air that's
relatively dry. You breathe out
air that's very humid. You know,
if you take a a glass plate and you
breathe out on it, it gets foggy, right?
You could see water condense
because your breath is much more,
has much more water in it,
the air around us.
So we lose actually quite a
lot of water that way. Uh,
through sweat and other activities,
you lose more water so that your
daily loss balances your daily intake.
Now what if you drink more water?
What if you drink? What if you're,
I know there's a lot of water
bottles in the room here.
A lot of you carry water around with
you and you drink water constantly
throughout day.
What happens?
Yeah,
you drink more water than this.
If you ingest 3.1 liters per water,
then you've got to lose
3.1.
You've got to lose 3.3 liters of water.
And normally what you lose in your
lungs and by sweat and other mechanisms,
it doesn't change. What changes is the
amount that you, that you use in urine.
So you're all familiar with this.
If you drink more water one day than you
did the day before, you're going to, uh,
you're, you're going
to produce more urine.
Go to the bathroom more often.
I don't know another way
to say it. Well, I do know,
I don't want to say it any other
way. Uh, what, what if you,
what if instead of water,
you s you,
you decided on another
day not to eat any salt.
I can eat any salt during the day.
Okay.
What would happen?
Well,
you would need to maintain
your salt concentration high.
Needed to maintain the
salt concentration high.
Yeah,
your kidney has to lose a little
bit of salt. It can't recover 100%.
So if you ate no salt at all,
you can't recover 100% of it.
You're going to lose a little bit
of the salt through your urine. It,
it can't recover 100% of the salt.
So you can only lose a little
bit of salt through your urine.
Yeah.
Uh, and, but if you didn't eat any salt,
then your sodium concentration
is going to drop.
It would want to drop,
but your body won't allow that to happen.
The kidneys won't allow that to happen.
So if it notices that your sodium
concentration is going down,
but you're not bringing any salt,
more sodium men,
how else can it change the concentration?
It could decrease the volume of water
in your body so it could produce more
watery urine or urine with more watering.
So try this experiment.
Don't eat any salt means you
probably can't go to the dining hall,
but if you don't eat any salt for a day,
you will notice that you're
producing more urine.
If you weigh yourself in the morning,
you weigh yourself at night,
your weight will go down.
Okay?
Over the course of one day. That's
why it's easy to lose a pound or two.
You can do that by just
restricting salt in your diet.
But it's a nice example of how your
body and how the kidney in particular,
uh,
senses what concentrations are present
in your body and adjust what it can
depending on what you're eating in order
to maintain what's important and what's
important is the concentration
of extracellular sodium
has to be at the right
level so that your brain and
your heart can function properly.
Okay.
That's it for a renal physiology.
In the section this afternoon
we'll talk about dialysis.
Dialysis is the technology developed
by biomedical engineers over the last
century that allows people to live
without normal kidney function.
My performing some of these
essential functions outside the body.